[Music]
our series we call it a more perfect
union aims to show that what unites us
as Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning we're
introducing you to a grocery store owner
in a remote Alaska community he went the
extra mile to make sure his customers
got the food and supplies they needed
when the coronavirus well left them
stranded CBS this morning Saturday
Cohoes as Dana Jacobson shows us his
remarkable story in southeastern Alaska
the town of Gustavus prides itself on
its closeness to nature
well we're a small community our economy
pretty much revolves around the tourist
industry
we're the Gateway to Glacier Bay
National Park there are no roads to
Gustavus it's only accessible by charter
plane or ship as Alaskans you know we're
pretty resourceful and we're kind of
used to this kind of thing we're cut off
by Nature up here
Alaska's state-run ferry is a critical
service providing transport and
delivering supplies to this remote
community but when a short shut down for
repairs was extended because of kovat 19
the town was left without options for
months businesses like Kelley
McLaughlin's gallery and coffee shop
were struggling things like thousand
pounds of coffee beans and orders of
milk there's no way I would be able to
afford shipping everything up over on
sea planes Joshua Parker or Tosh as he's
known by the locals thank you
runs Gustavus is only grocery store and
had the only ship in town able to make
supply runs just on a gamble the gamble
was you know what happens if the ferry
quit we would be totally cut off so
let's make this investment in this boat
kind of his insurance policy
that gamble paid off keeping the town of
450 residents supplied with food by
making weekly voyages to the state
capital of Juneau the 60 mile trek takes
14 hours by sea a little more than what
people are used to from their local
grocer and you know I I wish we could
just have a truck pull up to the back of
our store and open up and there's all
the groceries for the week that'd be
really slick but it's just you know in
rural Alaska it's not the way it is it
feels like you're a lifeline for the
people there right now these are all
neighbors these are friends they're
people you care about we're gonna do
whatever it takes and it's not just
groceries virtually everything coming in
to Gustavus arrives aboard Tasha's ship
we're bringing all kinds of stuff for
people be it lumber I mean if you need a
new fridge we'll try to find a fridge
and get it brought in here so whatever
people need yeah I mean everything from
building supplies to food everything
comes in roll-on/roll-off that ferry and
and he had to replace that somehow what
has that meant to your town to have him
taking care of everyone in that sort of
way if we didn't have any way to get our
groceries and supplies and whatever here
a lot of people would have to move away
go somewhere else is this hitting you
financially well sure I mean there's no
question that running the boat is
exponentially more expensive than using
the ferry the gal that does our books
has a conniption everyday you know it's
not a good time to be raising prices of
groceries that's for sure so we've been
holding the prices just eaten the
difference to get that boat keep the
prices the same it was huge I wouldn't
have been able to operate look out for
your neighbor that's kind of the
attitude we have here we care about each
other we take care of each other and
right now more than ever that's probably
a message I think people need so that's
what I would say with that
for CBS this morning I'm Dana Jacobson
look out for your neighbor you go Tosh
we're happy to say that the Gustavus
ferry is now back up it's running people
in town told us they are grateful to
Tosh for helping them for more than six
months while the ferry was shut down
you know guys frito-lay that makes those
wonderful barbecue lay potato chips they
have a campaign that says joy givers and
so when I think of joy givers you think
of people like Tosh he's got a nice face
kind heart really nice guy a joy giver
yes true Gail although I will I will say
I prefer the plain Lay's potato chips to
the barbecue